We've talked here before
about the health care disparities
that minority adults
have come to expect in this country.
Well, now there's a new report
that children
of all minority groups
also face disparities in care.
In a review of studies
done over a five year
period, researchers
found that overall,
the literature reveals
widespread patterns
of inequitable treatment
across pediatric specialties.
Those include specialties,
everything from neonatal
care to end of life care.
Joining me now to talk about her
findings is Dr.
Nia Hurd Garrett.
She's a pediatrician and researcher
who oversaw the review.
Thank you so much for being with us
from from neonatal care,
from the beginning of life
to the end of life
and across all specialties.
What did you find?
Yes.
From the very first moments of life,
all the way to the last moments of life
for children,
we're seeing disparities
in almost every aspect of pediatric care.
And as a pediatrician
and as a mom, it's pretty disheartening.
But every almost every single specialty
we have, we found disparities.
And the one that shows one of the greater
disparities is in pain management.
If a kid breaks his arm tumbling
or sprains an ankle, why roller skating?
Children of color
are less likely to get those painkillers.
Explain the disparity here.
Absolutely.
There's been so much research,
especially in the emergency
room department,
about pain management
in minorities, youth.
So black and Hispanic
youth are less likely
to get the pain medicine
that they need despite
having a bone
fracture, appendicitis, migraine
and even those that are getting a finger
or toe
replaced are less likely
to get pain medicine.
And that is absolutely unacceptable.
Is it clear why?
So we think a lot of these disparities
and and inequities that we see
are driven
by structural racism
and implicit bias and other factors
that are pervasive
not only in our society,
but also in our health care systems.
We need to do more research to understand
exactly why we're seeing this.
But one of the things we did in
our study
is taking out the
the argument that it's only insurance.
The reason why people aren't
getting the care that they need
is because they don't have insurance.
And that is not true for the study.
We controlled for that.
That means we made sure
that all of these children had insurance
and we're still seeing these disparities.
So they all had insurance.
Are there economic levels
in which they are treated differently
based on the communities
in which they live or
the income of their families?
Absolutely.
There there needs
to be more work in this space
because we know that
even though children have insurance,
all insurance is not created equal.
So if you have public insurance
or you have commercial insurance
or private insurance,
there are still levels
within those insurances.
So there is possibilities
that even because
even though you have insurance,
doesn't mean you're going
to get the top quality care.
But even despite that,
even looking at those
that only had Medicaid insurance
or only had private insurance,
those disparities by race and ethnicity
still persisted.
So it didn't really matter
that you only had
a certain type of insurance.
What seem to really be
the drivers here were race and ethnicity.
And that is, again, a very unfortunate.
And the pediatrician and a mom.
It certainly is.
And last for the moms
who are watching and dads to
what do they do with this?
Well, how do they
then advocate for
care for their children?
Absolutely.
I think there
needs to be a multi-level approach
to this.
I don't want there to read this study
and just leave
with a heavy heart and say, what do I do?
You know, my kid needs care.
I need help
and then be scared to interact
with the health care system.
So there are things that I think
parents and caregivers can do,
advocating for their children.
You know your child
best and trying to push
for the care that they need.
But it shouldn't
only be on the patient and family.
Our health care systems
need to review their policies
and look at their data
to make sure that we're not exacerbating
or making disparities
inequities worse for kids
and then for society.
Policymakers and policy.
Politicians
can help
to make these inequities better
by investing in communities
and making sure there are good,
solid systems for children and families.
Dr.
Nia Heard Garris,
thank you for doing the work
and thank you for the conversation.